So um my question basically is uh how do
you or how was the canon of the Bible
put together?
It's it was a process.
How do you what are the criterias to
identify holy scripture? Basically
the canon is a process entrusted to the
church. So you got to be careful though.
Some people think that the church
was debating over every single book of
the New Testament. So, let me give you a
little history and I'll give you a
website, a YouTube channel to go more in
depth.
From the get-go, the four gospels,
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John, no doubt
about their authenticity.
They're all apostles of Jesus, right?
Which one?
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
Not Not Luke.
Not Mark and Luke. Okay. Yeah. So from
the beginning, Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John, no dispute. They were accepted
universally as well as Acts because Luke
wrote, Luke wrote Acts, no dispute. 13
letters of Paul, no dispute. I say 13
because Hebrews, it was disputed whether
it's from Paul or not. So right away
from the beginning, Matthew, Mark, Luke,
John, Acts, 13 letters of Paul accepted.
So 13 + 5 is what?
uh 18
18. So those right away no dispute.
Now what was the criteria that the
Christians look to
to determine whether this book was truly
from the apostles or the period of the
apostles and inspired? Well, some of the
criteria first was apostolicity. What
does that mean? Do we know this book was
written during the time of the apostles
under their supervision oposes?
Right. That's one. Second criteria or
criterion. It's part of criteria was did
the major seeds of Christianity
the universal church received these
books early on as being inspired and
handed to them from the apostles. That
was the second.
So the disciples of the apostles also
wrote the canon of the Bible. Right.
Yes. So that's why was it something
passed down from the apostles with their
because even if an apostle had a
disciple wrote it did that writing of
the disciple was it written during the
time of the apostles with their approval
that's why it's called apostolicity
yes
it doesn't have to be an apostle
but was it written during the time of an
apostle with the approval apostle I'm
going to give you example unanimous
teaching of the church is John Mark
wrote the Gospel of Mark with Peter's
approval
because John Mark traveled with the
apostles. He traveled with Paul
Barnabas. He traveled with Peter. And
when Mark wrote down the gospel
in Rome, he was writing down the
preaching of Peter and it says Peter
approved of it being published and
passed on. That's called apostolicity.
Okay.
Okay. So the second is this is the
second though you have to remember when
they're looking back later they want to
look at the early records did the
churches the major seas of Christianity
major seas is Alexandria Egypt Jerusalem
Constantinople Rome
right
and Antioch
Antioch yeah
did these major seas where the apostles
went and did miracles and established
bishops and sabbath churches did they
received these books early on as from
the apostles meaning the period of the
apostles whether it's written by a
disciple that was another criteria part
of the criteria and also
if we know these books are from the
apostles Matthew Mark Luke and John and
Acts that we know and the 13 letters the
apostles and those under them will not
contradict established teaching so if a
book claims to come from them but
contradicts the books that we already
know to be from them established then it
can't be from them unless the apostles
and their followers were confused.
So it had to be sound in its teaching
and in its practice.
Okay, I see because there are a lot of
forgeries also I heard of like the
gospel of Barnabas or something like
this.
Well, Epistle of Barnabas is different
from the Gospel of Barnabas. Epistle of
Barnabas was written in the first
century and attributed Barnabas.
Yeah. And also like the nakamadi like
the gnostics they have some
no
crazy gospels
no basis to be authentic because
nagamadi is gnostic right
unless we believe Jesus didn't truly
become flesh the Christ only appeared in
human form or possessed a human being
named Jesus and abandoned him that would
not have been the worldview of the Jews
of the first century
most certainly not
so obviously they're not even in
consideration why because the world view
ofnosticism coming out of Gnostic Greek
philosophy. Matter is evil,
right? So you want to be liberated from
your body because the Greeks believed in
immortality of the soul because his body
is evil. You want to discard it. Matter
is evil. So then they mix that
philosophy with Christ saying, "See
Christ, the divine Christ either just
looked human but he went over and became
or he entered this man named Jesus and
then abandoned him when he got killed."
We know for a fact the Jew Jesus even if
you don't think he claimed to be God did
not share that worldview because as a
Jew he shared the worldview of the Old
Testament that taught God created the
world good though fallen he will restore
it and God will raise the dead in their
bodies not discard them.
Yeah.
So nasticism doesn't even have a claim.
Nagamari doesn't even have a claim.
I see.
So I have a second question. May I ask?
Yeah, you can ask God, bro, if I can
answer.
So I had this thought that um is it
possible in this day and age that there
are more prophets or are there no more
prophets being born ever again?
If you follow the tradition of the
churches established by the apostles,
the replacement of the apostles are
bishops. If you read the apostles, they
appointed bishops to take their place.
So the bishop is now in the role of an
apostle. We don't look to prophets and
apostles like Moses and Peter. The
bishops were their replacement. Whereas
in the Old Testament, you had succession
of prophets that would succeed prophets.
So this prophet came, another came to
take his place. In the New Testament,
the apostles and the prophets that were
with them taught the bishops take our
place. They stand in our place. And
that's why we talk about apostolic
succession. Meaning the apostles laid
hand up bishops and trusted them to
faith. They were now the leaders who
would now take over after the apostles
left.
Okay. So there are no more prophets
being born. Like the cannon is not
expanding. It's impossible.
You don't believe. finished.
Yeah. Once the apostles
will always be
once the apostles leave the earth and
they trust the bishops in their care,
that means everything God wants the
church to have and know until Christ
returns has already been revealed and
preserved in the church.
So, but is it possible to have like
prophetic dreams or something like this?
Oh, yeah. You can have dreams and
visions. Yeah. In fact, in the Catholic
church, okay, now you're asking me
something different. In the Catholic
church and Orthodox church, you have
visionaries
who actually have visions, dreams that
are believed to be from God. But these
dreams and visions obviously clarify or
confirm what has already been
established. Yes, we have. They're
mystics, visionaries. There are plenty
of them in the Orthodox and Catholic
churches. Yes, that is believed. Yep.
And on top of that, the Catholic Church
and the Orthodox Church recognizes that
God can even send
angels, saints, the Holy Mother, what
they call apparitions to actually come
to individuals, speak to them and
announce certain things that will happen
in that let's say 20th century or 21st
century. Yes, that is that is something
accepted by the Catholic and Orthodox
churches. Hence, Fatima, our lady of
Fatima, bonafideed apparition of the
blessed mother, confirmed by the
Catholic Church where she appeared to
three children, humble children. She
didn't appear to a bishop or a priest,
humble children. Why? Because God says
the kingdom belongs to children. And you
must humble yourself as a child if you
want to be great in the kingdom. And she
revealed to them the mysteries, they
call them the mysteries of Fatima, which
had to do with communism and Russia and
the impact it would have on the world.
Yes.
I see. I see. So, have you ever
experienced anything like it yourself?
Not on that level. No, I'm not a I'm not
a visionary.
Nothing supernatural.
Supernatural stuff has happened to me
all the time, but that's not on the
level of where it is now binding upon
the faithful because the holy mother
told me, "Make sure you reveal this to
the pope." And the pope then
speaks about it.
That is something personal for me and
those who are exposed to it. So, I don't
want you to think you're a visionary and
you've been sent by God to speak to us.
Yeah, that's that's the problem because
sometimes I think the dream might mean
something, but like you can never 100%
sure tell if it's not some um if I'm not
being deceived by Satan, you know?
Yeah, you can be. But how you know
you're not deceived?
You number one, you have to be in solid
standing with the church in a submission
to the church as well as the leadership
of the church. So if you're by yourself
sitting at home and you're doing
Christianity on your own, number one,
you're in violation. You're in sin.
Yeah. I've been going to different
churches, but I haven't decided to which
church I will belong because I'm truly I
truly believe only for a year, not even
a year.
Good. You're getting there. But don't
base it on your dreams and visions to
become a Christian because even Satan
can reveal himself to people and demons
and convince them that they are prophets
but then inspire them to teach false
teaching like Muhammad.
Be careful because Jesus warned us of
that. Satan appears as an angel of
light. They'll be false prophets, false
Christ. They'll even do miracles, but
then they'll contradict the revelation
established, preserved by God. And many
people who don't know the Bible, are not
grounded in the faith, will be deceived
and follow them. Like this Mai character
who's a fake. Look how many people are
following him.
So you want to make sure you're not
demonized. Find a church. Fast.
Submit to the church. Fast. Come under
leadership. Fast. And let them pray over
you, watch over you and guide